[Music]
could you speak
to
or define selective abstraction because
this this is something that might be
worth digging into sure
selective abstraction is when
we take one detail from a big picture
and we construct
the story of that whole big picture
around the detail
an example it's probably a common
example but even in my own life is like
i can come to work and i can have a good
day at work and feel like i'm doing good
things and i'm helping people i
generally can feel good about things but
then if i can't find my keys when i'm
leaving and this is really happened and
then you know i'm frustrated now and i'm
frustrated with myself and when i
finally find my keys or i get people to
help me find my keys the narrative
that's going on in my head is like what
a loser right i mean you can't even find
your car keys to drive home what the
hell is wrong with you and like that's
the story and then i can get home and
like my wife could ask me how was your
day i'm like ah you know
it's a terrible day because i'm
incompetent right because like i built
the story of the whole day
around what the salient negative right
the thing that triggered in me
you know my own susceptibility to
thinking i'm not i'm not good enough and
what i'm doing isn't worthwhile enough i
know look what's wrong with me
and that's selective abstraction because
that was probably 10 minutes of my day
but my brain builds the whole story of
the day which is my story of myself
right around that negative thing
yeah it's uh
selective attention is a hell of a thing
right it's
it's like you buy that and you buy a new
car
and all of a sudden everyone's driving
the same car but of course
those cars are already out there
you're just paying more attention now
and that's so big because this is all
about salience biases what are we paying
attention to right and trauma makes us
pay attention to the negative that's why
we think the world is less safe of a
place or that we're less competent
people like this is the danger that we
we use selective abstraction and
salience biases and attribution biases
where something negative happens then
i'm going to attribute it to me
and i see this all the time where you
know something negative may happen next
door a person had nothing to do with but
they feel that it's their fault because
we get enough of this in ourselves and
we we literally forget who we are
or what we're worth which is why people
will stay in jobs that they hate when
they could try something different or
they'll stay in abusive relationships
when they could end the abusive
relationship and not enter another one
right it's this this where does all that
end up it ends up in learned
helplessness and
learned helplessness pushes people
towards more trauma and very often
towards death
could you say more about that
when you say towards death
because the the accumulation of trauma
makes people more and more desperate for
ways of of coping it's like you had made
that you talked about drug addiction and
we talked about the decrease in role
performance and the shame that comes
along with it and the stigma i mean
nobody decides you know i'm going to use
drugs because what i what i want to do
is ruin my life like no one makes that
decision right so if we look at as you
were saying
dr mattei was saying it's like look at
the pain in the person like
where did that come from and not always
but a lot of times where where drug
abuse and drug addiction comes from is
it comes from pain and suffering and a
desperation to feel different so more
pain and suffering means people are more
likely to repeat maladaptive patterns
that lead them to more trauma and
they're more likely to feel desperate
for soothing in a way that can for
example pave the way to substance use
because the imagine like a set of
blinders that it starts off they're
outside of our peripheral vision so
they're not affecting us at all but as
time goes on they can encroach more and
more and more as a person has more
trauma less healthy coping mechanisms a
more negative view of self a more
negative view of the world and then the
blinders come in and at some point the
blinders are so narrow that all the
person sees it could be is basically a
helpless and hopeless picture
right and that's where a lot of suicide
comes from yeah absolutely and where a
lot of accidental deaths come from so
often the goal is when i think about
what are we doing in trauma treatment
and the image that's in my head a lot is
i imagine a set of of blinders a person
is just peeking through with one eye and
we're trying to pull them out so they
see the breadth of truth right the
breadth of their perspective
allows that person to again see truth
and remember oh like an example you know
i absolutely understood at one point in
time that violence is not acceptable in
my life
right i understood that and i don't
believe that any less now than i did
then
but boy i kind of forgot it in the
middle
because the person forgot that they
could have a life free of violence or
that they deserve a life free of
violence that's where this narrowing of
blinders and the change in emotion and
how emotion impacts our memories and
tells us what our memories mean
right the memory of something happy with
other people can go from being a memory
that says right i can do anything and i
can interact with people and they like
me and want me to be around to a memory
of something that's impossibly lost for
the person and again that's not true but
if you see it as impossibly lost
it is unless there's some process that
leads you to a place where you remember
what's true that you forgot
you